alors ici nous nous trouvons devant ce
qui serait le golgotha
et ce qui a donné à gordon l'idée que ça
devait être le golgotha c'est ce que
fait que cette falaise que vous voyez là
à grosso modo la forme d'un crâne vous
pouvez distingué avec un peu
d'imagination les deux yeux le nez on
voyait la bouche manière beaucoup plus
claire il ya quelques années de cela
mais il ya eu des éboulements de terrain
ces derniers temps et la bouche a
disparu d'autre part la gare d autobus a
été réhaussée et a donc à cacher une
partie du golgotha ça c'était délibéré
s'était voulue pour que précisément le
lieu soit défigurée alors ce lieu sur le
plan géologique est ici une faille dans
un éperon rocheux qui commence un peu
plus au nord est qu'ils se dirigent vers
le sud qui traversait la route et se
prolonger jusque sur le mont du temps ce
qui voudrait dire que nous sommes ici
dans une partie du mont moriah le
l'endroit où abraham a sacrifié isaac
exactement et il ya eu donc ici une une
coupure qui a été fait artificiellement
dans cet éperon rocheux pour pouvoir
faire passer la route ici qui va du
reste on est en direction donc de du
jourdain foncé d'autre part que cet
endroit était un lieu d'exécution et on
est situé si l'endroit à l'endroit où
vraisemblablement
etienne a été supplicié parce qu'on
trouve ici à quelque distance de là à
une église édifiée qui est dédié à
saint-etienne donc les deux là
vraisemblablement non loin de l'endroit
où a lieu son martyre
la technique d'exécution des condamnés
c'était de les précipiter du haut de la
falaise et de les achever à coude clair
si on arrive en bas n'était pas mort
où jésus at il été crucifié alors là
c'est quelque chose aussi qui est
inhabituel dans notre mentalité parce
que nous sommes habitués à de véritables
images d'epinal à ce niveau là où on
voit les trois croix qui se lève au
sommet de la colline or la construction
s'élève youth les lieux en bas là où
sont les autobus pour fois pour que les
passants puissent assister à l'exécution
et puis c'était un avertissement voilà
ce qui vous attend si vous déroger au
pouvoir romain les croix n'était pas du
tout autre comme on leur présente et
on a l'habitude de représenter des
froids qui font plusieurs mètres de haut
mais les trois étaient pratiquement à
hauteur d'homme d'autre part la croix ce
n'était pas du tout la croix latines
telle qu on la représente la croix elle
avait la forme d'un thé et le poteau
verticale rester en place entre les deux
exécutions est ce que le bleu la croix
que le condamné porter n'était pas là
croate elle qu on la représente dans les
scènes où jésus porte la croix on ne
portait que la poutre transversale qu'on
appelait le patibulaire d'où
l'expression avoir une mine patibulaire
et
et la manière du crucifié n'était pas du
tout cette qu'on vous présente aussi on
a retrouvé en 1915 70 ici dans faisons
une roue sur le mont des oliviers
le squelette d'un crucifié dans un
ossuaire qui portait le nom du défunt
portait le nom de johan and who you are
annan bennes agricoles et quand on a
ouvert l'ossuaire on a découvert les os
d'un homme d'une trentaine 32 30 à 35
ans à peu près et les eaux d'un enfant
de quatre ans donc le pain uran et le
fils qui s'appelait yohanan aussi qu'ils
étaient enterrés et c'était ben d'agde
accueille sa venue
annan et son fischer annan le fils du
pendu
la crucifixion était comparée à une
pendaison
et et on sait que les romains avaient
l'habitude qu'ont pendant que les
condamnés étaient en train d'agoniser
sur la croix de massacrer nos familles
devant leurs yeux
donc ce jeune garçon de 4 ans a dû être
mis à mort en même temps que son père
qui était en train d'agoniser sur la
croix
maintenant ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on a découvert les la première fois
la trace d'une crucifixion est
intéressant de noter que le clou en
question n'étaient pas enfoncé comme on
le représente dans les scènes de la
passion dans les deux pieds superposés
nationaux créés dans les talons les deux
talons du coup sifflet été transpercée
par un énorme clou d'une de 12 à 15 cm
de long environ ce qui veut dire que la
position du crucifié sur la croix était
celle là
et quant au coût qui était dans les été
enfoncé si dans les avant bras on a
retrouvé les traces du cloud sur les os
de l'avant-bras du crucifié
donc on sait exactement aujourd'hui
commente été pratiqué une crucifixion
il y avait une autre manière du crucifié
c'était de placer les deux les deux
criées du crucifié de chaque côté du
poteau verticale et de mettre un clou
dans chaque pied dans chaque salon bon
comment jésus a été crucifié ne sait pas
exactement mais en tout cas dans une de
ces deux méthodes la ressource vous
imaginez la position vraiment
inconfortable qu'on pouvait avoir sur la
croix pour prolonger l'agonie on mettait
un ami à mi-pente disons d'avoir la
moitié de la croix espèce de siège sur
lequel le crucifié pouvait prendre appui
aussi pour pouvoir respirer un peu plus
à l'aise ce qui faisait que l'agonie
pouvait durer les heures et des heures
voire des jours et des jeux plusieurs
jours en tout cas bon c'est que jésus
n'est pas mort comme ça il a été il est
mort quand il a résolu de le faire
sortie de la ville pour aller vers
l'endroit appelé le crâne ce qui se dit
en hébreu golgotha c'est là qu'ils le
crucifièrent et avec lui deux autres un
de chaque côté jésus au milieu
pilâtre est déjà aussi un écriteau qu'il
plaça sur la croix il était écrit juste
nazareth le roi des juifs beaucoup de
juifs lure cette inscription parce que
l'endroit où jésus fut crucifié étaient
près de la ville étaient écrites en
hébreu et en grec et en latin les chefs
des prêts des juifs d'hier tapis là tu
n'écris pas le roi des juifs mais plutôt
cet homme a dit je suis le roi des juifs
il a répondu ce que j'ai écrit je les
écris à présent pacifiée jésus les
soldats pris à ses vêtements il enfile 4
pas une pour chaque soldat
et rire aussi sa tunique était sans
couture d'une seule pièce depuis l'eau
jusqu'en bas et se dire entre eux ne la
déchire on pas mais tire au sort pour
savoir à qui elle sera c'est ainsi que
ça qu'on puisse cette parole de
l'écriture et se sont partagé mes
vêtements ils ont tiré au saumon abus
voilà ce que firent les soldats près de
la croix de jésus se tenait sa mère la
soeur de sa mère marie la femme de clo
passe et marie de magdala jésus vit sa
mère et près d'elle d'ici peu qu'il
aimait dit à sa mère femme voici ton
fils
odyssud voici ta mère et les ce moment
le disent ils le pourraient l'a pris
avec lui après cela jésus qui savait que
tout est accompli dit afin que
l'écriture soit se réalise pleinement
j'ai soif il y avait là un vaste plan de
vinaigre soldats remplir une éponge à
fixer à une bronze des europe et la
prochaine de sa bouche jésus prit le
vinaigre il dit tout est accompli plus
il baissa la tête et randy l'esprit
c'était la préparation de la fête du
shabbat et ce shabbat était un grand
jour solennel craignant que les corps ne
reste sur la croix pendant le shabbat
justement des rats pilates comprises les
gens ont crucifié parce que quand on
disait les jambes vous comprenez on
pouvait plus prendre appui sur les
jambes et à la mort intervenez en
quelques minutes donc on a hâte et la
mort il fallait que les tout soit
terminé pour le shabbat
soldats prix revient nous briser les
gens du premier puis du second des
condamnés qui avaient été crucifié jésus
quand ils s'approchèrent de jésus il fit
qu elle vu qu'il était déjà mort ne lui
brisa pas les jambes mais un des soldats
je transpire ça le côté avec une lance
le site en une en sortie du sang et de
l'eau celui qui a vu ces choses en rend
témoignage son témoignage est vrai il
sait que il dit la vérité afin que vous
croyez aussi en effet ceci est arrivé
afin que ce passage de l'écriture soit
accompli aucun de ces zones sera brisée
et ailleurs l'écriture dit encore ils
verront celui qu'ils ont transpercé
donc ici nous nous trouvons d'avoir un
endroit qui montre que nous étions ici
dans un lieu qui était un lieu exploiter
d'exploitation agricole important c'est
ce qui a convaincu gordon que nous
étions ici certainement dans l'endroit
du golgotha ce qui nous est dit qu à
côté de l'endroit où jésus a été
crucifié il y avait un jardin et on a
retrouvé effectivement ici des traces
d'un jardin et notamment une citerne le
système pour emmagasiner l'eau et cette
citerne et est énorme elle est une
capacité de
contenance absolument extraordinaire et
qui permet d'irriguer une surface
importante donc ici c'était une
propriété d'un homme riche et en même
temps c'était un endroit où il y avait
donc un jardin qui était exploité
notamment pour la vigne on a retrouvé un
petit peu plus loin un pressoir à vin et
par conséquent ici cela correspond
vraiment aux données vangelis vous
pouvez jeter un coup d'oeil dans la
citerne si vous voulez il ya de l'eau
d'ailleurs à l'heure actuelle ça vous
donne une petite idée là profondeur vous
donne une petite idée et tout ça voyez
vous si tout ce qui est recouvert de
tuiles rouges c'est la citerne donc vous
imaginez la capacité
alors vous apercevez c'est un pressoir à
vin qui était dans ce jardin dont il est
question ce qui pousse bien qu'on était
dans un jardin regardez comment se
présenter un pressoir à vin et on met
telegraph couper là où non droit qui
pavés on mettait une
barrière des pin qui servait de filtre
et on mettait un portique en bois ou sur
lesquels étaient suspendus des cordes et
le vin et le raisin été foulée aux pieds
parce que on doit écraser le raisin
juste suffisamment pour que le juge soit
exprimé mais il ne faut pas broyer les
pépins de raisin
car s'ils ont droit les pépins du raisin
ça va donner un goût amer aux vins
alors on se suspendait un décor assez
corde qui pendait sur le portique pour
ne pas glisser et c'était un travail
très pénible donc on changeait les
équipes de temps cela assez fréquemment
et pendant qu'une équipe était en train
de fouler le grain et il y avait les
autres qui chantait pour lui de redonner
du courage elle chantait les psaumes
qu'on appelle les psaumes à chanter sur
la grille titre vous avez d'epson qui
porte ce titre a chanté sur la grille
titre dit il ça vient du mot gâteau
hébreu qui signifie le pressoir donc
c'était les cris les chants que l'on
chantait pour remercier dieu d'abord et
deuxièmement pour encourager les
laissez les foules acquis foulée le gras
alors ici nous sommes dans une
structure qui est un tombeau du 1er
siècle donc il ya de l'époque de jésus
vous êtes rentré dedans et vous vous
êtes vous avez vu tout vous rendre
compte de la somme de travail que
représente à l'époque où on n'a pas les
moyens dont on dispose aujourd'hui pour
creuser un tombeau de cesse de ce type
là donc il faut vraiment être riche pour
pouvoir se payer un tombeau de ceux de
cette catégorie là vous êtes entré ici
dans la première chambre qui est la
chambre des plats et ce tombeau il a
quelque chose de très spécial qui n'est
pas courant dans les tombeaux de
l'époque il a une seule chambre
funéraire est logiquement qu'à une seule
chambre funéraire elle est dans le
prolongement de la chambre des pleurs et
non pas sur le côté comme ici bon il
faut vous représentez qu'à l'époque la
porte elle était beaucoup moins grande
que ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui elle
était à peu près moitié moins grand donc
il fallait se baisser pour pouvoir
entrer et c'est ce qui nous est raconté
que les apôtres ont dû se baisser pour
pouvoir voir ce qu'il y avait à
l'intérieur
vous avez vu à l'intérieur les trois
reposoir si j'avais de chaque côté c'est
la chambre funéraire quand quelqu'un
décéder on l'enveloppé dans des
bandelettes avec des aromates et on ne
déposait sur interpose war
et il restera environ un ordre et un an
après on récupérer les eaux la chair
était décomposée ont récupéré réseau on
émettait dans des petites boîtes en
terre cuite ou en pierre qui me placer
dans des niches qui était situé dans une
autre partie de la pièce federer c'était
ce qu'on appelait être rassemblés à ces
instances être décédé et la tombe et
n'était prête pour d'autres sépultures
quand ensuite la famille c'était une
propriété familiale une tombes dont
étaient rassemblés dans le tombeau ses
pairs
on creuse et d'autres chambres
funéraires et vous pouvez avoir des
tombeaux
kvx chambre funéraire qui était selon
l'importance de la famille ou sait
l'importance de ce qui était enterré
dans cet endroit là donc
jésus a été enterré de cette manière là
et
logiquement n'est condamné les condamnés
à mort n'étaient pas enterrés dans des
tombes ils étaient jetés à la fosse
commune et dieu n'a pas permis que son
fils soit je tiens la fosse commune
parce qu'ils devaient ressuscité donc
automatiquement il a permis que c'est un
risque et et joseph d'areva t était un
disciple de jésus l'accueil dans sa
propre tombe vous inquiète jamais
personne n'avait été mis
maintenant on peut se représenter le ce
qui s'est produit le jour de la deûle à
lille tenant sur vivement et de la
résurrection valliot le texte
après cela joseph d'arimathie que les
disciples de jésus mais en secret par un
des frères aînés sous-chef juifs
demandent à pilate la permission
d'enlever le corps de jésus puis la
queue lui permis il va donc y enlevant
le corps de jésus niveau des hommes qui
auparavant étaient allés trouver jésus
de nuit 20 aussi il a porté un mélange
d'environ 30 kg de mire et d'aloès il
prit donc le corps de jésus l'enveloppé
dans des bandelettes avec les aromates
comme c'est la coutume dans ce livre
chez les juifs or il y avait un jardin à
l'endroit où jésus avait été crucifié et
dans ce jour-là un ton bonnafous
personne n'avait encore jamais été mis
celui là qui déposait jésus parce que
c'était la préparation de la pac des
juifs et que le tombeau était proche et
de fait il était proche de l'endroit où
on était tout à l'heure le premier jour
de la semaine marie de magdala se rendit
au tombeau de bon matin alors qu'il
faisait encore sombre elle vu que la
pierre avait été enlevée alors la pierre
elle été roulé dans cette encoches que
vous voyez là
mais la tombe disons la pierre de ce
tombeau là elle avait disparu on n'a
jamais retrouvé alors on en avait ramené
une autre que vous voyez là
cleary et qui ressemble à celle qui
était voulait et même si
elle était moins grande que ce que dans
l'imaginaire maintenant c'était quand
même pour des femmes quelque chose de
très dur de pouvoir l'a roulé elle
courut trouver simon-pierre et l'autre
aux disciples jésus aimait le redis ils
ont enlevé le seigneur du tombeau ne
savons pas hulot me perds et l'autre du
cip sortir donc aller au tombeau ils
pourraient tous deux ensemble mais
l'autre disciples couru plus vite que
pierre et rival le premier tombeau il se
pencha voyez-vous il fallait se pencher
pour pouvoir entrer et vie les
bandelettes posé à terre cependant il
n'en sera pas à
simon lui qui ne suivaient arriva est en
train dans le tombeau il vit les
bandelettes
poser en fait s'est affaissé à terre le
texte de terme grec s'est affaissé à
terre le linge qu'on avait mis sur jésus
sur la tête de jésus n'était pas avec
les bandes mais entourée d'un enroulé
dans un endroit pas alors l'autre du sud
qui était arrivé le premier au tombeau
entre a aussi il veut et il crut à
qu'est ce qui l'a amené à voir et à
croire qu est ce qu il a vu qu'il a
amené à croire les les bonnes et les
bandelettes affaissé ça veut dire que
quand jésus est ressuscité
eh bien il n'a pas déroulé les
bandelettes il est passé au travers
et vous savez qu'il était passé au
travers de des murs qui étaient fermés
dans la chambre haute bien de la même
manière il est passé dans sa
résurrection au travers des bandelettes
et par conséquent tout cette espèce de
momies qui étaient créés par ces sept
ans bonnement s'est affaissé sur place
et c'est ce que les deux disciples et
région vue ils ont conclu qu'un miracle
avait eu lieu et que véritablement jésus
était ressuscité ils n'avaient pas
encore compris que d'après l'écriture
jésus devait ressuscité ensuite il
dissipe repartir chez eux cependant
marie se tenait devant bull le tombeau
elle pleurait tout en pleurant elle se
pencha pour garder dans le tombeau elle
vit deux anges habillés de blanc assis à
la place où jésus avait été couché son
oncle cordes juge avait été couché lana
la tête autre pied aux autres pied une
femme pourquoi pleures tu répondes hui
parce qu'ils ont enlevé mon seigneur je
ne sais pas où ils l'ont dit en disant
cela et se retourna et vu jésus debout
mais je ne savais pas que c'était juste
et lui jésus lui dit femme pourquoi
pleures tu qu'ils cherchaient tu pour ça
que c'était le jardinier lui dit
seigneur si c'est toi qui l'emportait
dit le foutu l'ami j'irai le prendre je
lui dit myriam là sur le tournage vient
d'ouvrir à boni c'est à dire m jésus lui
dit ne me retient pas ne me touche pas
car je ne suis pas encore remonté vers
mon père mais pas trouvé un frère edddy
là que je montre mon père et votre paie
faire mon dieu et votre dieu marie de
l'acda de la marque d'al ala l'émotion
dissiper avait vu cela et que le
seigneur lui avais dit ces choses
maintenant je voudrais vous faire
remarquer plusieurs choses ici les
ossuaires ces petits coqs de terre dans
lequel on mettait les ossements des
décors quand la chaire avait été
décomposé d'autre part je voudrais vous
faire remarquer aussi
ses poutres cessé entre actualité
qu'elles ont le rocher en eau ce sont
des endroits où on pose et des poutres
et s'il ya un endroit qui pavés ça c'est
authentique ça veut dire qu'il y avait
ici un espace devant le tombeau qui
était assez vaste et qui était protégé
par un toit donc une structure
permanente ça veut dire qu'il avait ici
des gens qui se rassemblent et et ça
jusqu'à à peu près 130 135 après jésus
christ la révolte de bar kokhba pourquoi
qui se rassembler ici et pourra se
rassemblent et on ici manifestement une
communauté judéo chrétienne qui se
souvenait que c'était l'endroit où jésus
avait été déposé
ce qui suit vous avez grosso modo
l'image d'un dut menorah un chandelier à
sept branches et le cheveu le chandelier
à sept branches à l'époque c'était le
symbole du christianisme ce n'était pas
la croix qui était symbole du
christianisme c'était le chandelier vous
avez ça dans l'apocalypse donc
l'argument selon lequel il n'y a pas de
tradition
comme dans le cas du saint sépulcre ne
tient pas à passer de 235 ou la
communauté chrétienne a été dispersée
judéo chrétienne a été dispersée on a
oublié ce lieu qu'on a retrouvé avec
gordon mais disons dans les premières
décennies après la crucifixion jésus on
se souvenait que c'était là que jésus
avait été crucifié vraisemblablement
alors vous avez aussi un trou voyez-vous
dans la dans le tombeau qui permettait
d'accéder directement c'est ce qu'on
appelle en effet slam l'âme de la tombe
c'était pour que la deûle à l'âme du
défunt puce allait venir librement
et quand nous lisons elle j écris du
début du xvième siècle qui s'appelle la
dictature des douze apôtres qui nous
explique comment les premiers chrétiens
prenez l'ascenseur nous est dit ceci
quand vous a semblé vous reprendre la
scène que celui qui préside 10 quand les
espèces ont été consacrés si quelqu'un
est pur qu'il vienne si quelqu'un ne
l'est pas qu'ils se repentent maranatha
pourquoi se repentir
marre parce que maranatha maranatha ça
signifie le seigneur vient
alors le cmuh revient aux derniers jours
mais pas nous montre qu' il n'y a plus
que cela dans ces tensions entre le
passé 1 est venu passer la mort et la
résurrection de jésus est un arabe
d'événements avenue son retour aux
derniers jours il ya aujourd'hui via le
temps présent dans lequel nous sommes
et ce temps là nous nous souvenons il
faut savoir que dans la mentalité brahic
on parlait hier de la pensée grecque de
la pensée juive est bien dans la pensée
juive se souvenir c'est pas simplement
un mémorial quelque chose qui touche une
réalité qui est disparue qui est morte
mais c'est réactualisé l'événement
quand je me souviens de la mort et de la
résurrection de jésus en prenant le pain
le vin je réactualise cet événement
et par conséquent dans ce moment de
sainte cène le seigneur est celui qui
vient il vient et il ne faut pas
simplement attendre sa venue au dernier
jour mais il faut attendre sa venue
maintenant il vient maintenant
je viens maintenant milieu de vous
et quand nous prenons le pain le vin de
la scène le seigneur est aussi présent
en tant que ressuscité qu'il était quand
il est venu au milieu de ses disciples
dans la chambre ou l'autre le soir de
pâques et qu'il viendra au dernier jour
il est aussi présent seulement la seule
différence c'est que pour l'heure voyons
pas nous ne pouvons pas nous voir avec
nos yeux de cher tandis que quand ils
interviennent et joue tout a eu le verra
et que se passera-t-il aux derniers
jours quand le seigneur viendra est bien
de rendre à chacun selon ses oeuvres
il apportera la belgique sont justes et
le jugement méchant
or on nous dit que parce que certains
des corinthiens ont pris la scène
indignement comme le rappelle a dit
hacker que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
beaucoup sont décédés à voir où sont
tombés malades mêmes sont décédés avant
leur temps et pas le dis si nous ne
jugions nous-mêmes ne serions pas juger
mais autrement si nous ne jugeons pas
nous mêmes nous sommes condamnés avec le
monde
pourquoi parce que quand le seigneur
reviendra au dernier jour il viendra
comme le juge le juge des derniers jours
et parce qu'il vient aujourd'hui et bien
déjà il est présent mieux de nous comme
celui qui me jugent et je dois me
présenter devant celui qui me jugent
donc je dois me jugez moi même pour ne
pas être jugé et condamné comme le monde
sera jugée au diané joue quand le
seigneur viendra
un autre une autre pensée avant que nous
ne partagions le pain le vin c'est
lorsque jésus chemine avec les disciples
qui vont à emmaüs
ces disciplines ne le reconnaissent pas
bien que jésus leur ouvre l'esprit pour
qu'ils comprennent les écritures et leur
explique en marchant tout ce qui le
concernait et il est très intéressant de
noter que c'est lorsque jésus prend le
pain et le vin rouge le pain le vin
qu'il reconnaisse
et
paradoxalement pendant tout le temps où
ne leur connaissait pas jésus était avec
eux et à partir dans une reconnaît jésus
disparaît devant leurs yeux
et voyez vous ça c'est aussi le sens de
la scène
dans la sainte cène nous nous souvenons
sans vous dire nous rendons présent le
seigneur il vient au milieu de nous et
je crois que là nous pouvons plus qu'un
dans un autre lieu évoquer ce souvenir
est cette réalité de sa présence le
seigneur est présent au milieu de nous
en cet instant parce qu'il est
ressuscité il est présent comme il était
le soir de pâques dans la chambre et
autres comme il l'était avec les
disciples quand il a pris la scène quand
il a rompu le pas
au sommet de la montagne au dessus de la
ville se trouve donc l'endroit où
abraham avait amené isaac la tradition
veut voir l'endroit où ils doivent faire
le sacrifice l'endroit c'est le mont
moriah et là bas ils abandonnent les lan
et eliezer son serviteur et ismaël sur
notre fils et lui et isaac continue vers
la montagne moria où aura lieu le
sacrifice n'aura pas lieu à cet endroit
là mille ans plus tard le roi david et
6-2 contre sa capitale alors j'ai
expliqué avec la capitale il l'a
construit en contrebas donc la ville
était dans la pente qui descend vers la
vallée parce que c'est là bas que je
trouve la villa côté de la source donc
ça c'est la ville de jérusalem la ville
antique la ville j'ai bu cn mon avis
doit faire sa capitale est à côté d'eux
au bas de cette ville coup une source la
source du garonne qui alimente la ville
en eau quand la ville va grandir elle va
s'étendre sur les murs sur la colline au
dessus et est là où ça le monde va
construire le temple david achète le
terrain d'art avenant au sommet de la
montagne et ce terrain va être le
terrain du temple le construit en bois
d'ébène en bois de cèdre venues du liban
en coraux en or et ce temple va durer
quatre cent dix ans au bout de quatre
cent dix ans d'existence arrive d'un but
que de nos hors droits de babylonie
détruit le temple et on part pour l'exil
le premier exil exil de babylone qui a
duré 70 ans sur saison on revient sur la
conduite de
nos choix et
rob bell et
on va appuyer par contre le temple à
l'époque donné des vrais de nesmy mais
c'est un temple très minime par rapport
au temple de salomon il est beaucoup
moins on n'est pas riche le bébé de l'or
on met du bronze dahu des bois d'ébène
on prend des bois le des bois locaux et
le texte devra nous rappelle que les
gens qui se rappelait le premier exil le
premier temple des anciens qui étaient
revenus pleurer envoyé en disant
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on va faire
c'est tout petit par rapport à ce
qu'était la splendeur du temps de salma
et vers la fin de ce temple y aura un
roi
très mauvais que tout le monde déteste
le roi hérode et eyrolles devaient
demander qu'est ce qui pourrait faire
pousser un peu plus aimé de son peuple
et un rabbin un survivant du massacre
parce qu'il ya eu des massacres et tous
les rabbins ce rabbin dit ben
reconstruit embellie le temps et érode
arrivent ils voient la montagne et il
disait je sais pas faire moi je fais du
grand il a construit ses arénas
construit sébastien il se faire du grand
saint massada la montagne est petit et
pour faire du grand il décide de faire
chaud suivant de construire un mur
autour de la montagne c'est la muraille
convient aujourd'hui c'est une muraille
et un mur de soutènement ils entourent
la muraille d'un mur de soutènement il
construit une esplanade de 500 mètres de
long sur 350 et la navy je peux faire du
grand est construit ce temple est
magnifique qui fait 50 m dos 50 m de
haut ces onze étages c'est pas classique
des bâtiments de l'époque c'est le plus
grand bâtiment de l'antiquité en marbre
en or et il fait ça en grand il
construit ce temple à jérusalem sur
cette montagne ce temps ne veut pas duré
très longtemps et rod est mort 80 vers
l'ère chrétienne et en 77 ans que ça
détruit par les romains donc la durée
quelque chose comme 4 81 ans au bout de
80 ans il est détruit par les romains
est de plus n'a pas été reconstruit
alors à l'époque romaine les romains
maîtres un temple sur l'esplanade
camp rom deviendra chrétienne avec
l'empereur constantin et détruisent des
temples païens en génération souvent sur
beaucoup de temps encore été construit
des églises pas ici parce que le
dans du temple n'est pas un lieu
important pour au contraire jésus avait
chassé les marchands du temple renversé
des tables c'est pas un lieu de culte
chrétien donc il n'y a rien à cet
emplacement jusqu'à ce qu'arrivent les
musulmans les musulmans arrive au 7e
siècle et le calife omar demande un
conseiller juifs de ses armées qu'est-ce
que je peux faire ici ou des marots
construit au temple alors on m'a dit bon
choix et swire lentement vacances le
temple mais il construit un lieu de
prière sur la montagne et y construit ce
bâtiment est le dôme doré qu'il est
inquiète un bâtiment en souvenir de
l'endroit du sacrifice puisque nous les
juifs disons que cet endroit où abraham
a sacrifié isaac les musulmans révère
abraham comme leurs ancêtres en disant
que le l'enfant qu'il emmenait ses
paysages mais séisme est l'ancêtre
maison donc la même histoire sur cette
même montagne et disons que c'est
l'endroit où ibrahim a amené son fils et
donc ils construisent un bâtiment qui
n'est pas une mosquée devant les
mosquées n'existe pas encore à l'époque
c'est un on est en 638 150 c'est juste
la création de l'islam les musulmans
sont des bédouins du désert des arabes
qui sont bédouins ils ont ils ont des
tentes en peau de chèvre en peau de
chameau n'ont jamais rien construit
c'est pour ça que quand tu décides de
construire le premier bâtiment de
l'islam ou en faire appel à des
bâtiments des bâtisseurs byzantin et les
bases des soeurs byzantin qu'est ce
qu'ils savent construire
des bases eric ce que l'auteur arthur
king ont peut-être vu à sa istanbul la
mosquée sainte sophie c'est vrai quand
une mosquée s'apaisent sainte-sophie
c'est qu'à l'origine ce n'est pas une
mosquée c'était une église et ça
ressemble beaucoup à ce bâtiment bleu
octogonale parce qu'en fait le premier
bâtiment construit par l'islam est une
église mais donc ce n'est pas une église
ce n'est pas non plus une mosquée une
mosquée s'est tournée aujourd'hui vers
la mecque j'ai dit aujourd'hui parce
qu'au départ la première direction la
prière comme m commence l'islam les
musulmans prient vers jérusalem parce
qu'il espère par ce à rallier les juifs
à l'islam très vite il va se rendre
compte que les juifs ne suffit pas et va
30 dirigé la prière vers la mecque c'est
pour ça que 50 ans après ce bâtiment est
construit une mosquée à jérusalem elle
est devant vous à gauche il dit le dôme
gris avec un bâtiment allongée ce
bâtiment une verge vers le sud vers la
mecque ça c'est la mosquée la troisième
lorsque sein du slam la mosquée d'el
aqsa j'entends hütthaler dire le nom de
mosquée d'omar n'y a pas de mosquée
d'omari c est une hausse que le mariage
aux réelles et pas là je sais que les
médias français aiment parler de
l'esplanade des mosquées de la mosquée
d'omar tout ça c'est de la récupération
politique dans le sens de l'unesco les
juifs on n'a rien à voir avec jérusalem
donc plus cette mosquée plus il ya deux
choses qui sont pas juives plus avant
une histoire mais ce n'est pas une
mosquée d'omar en arabe ça s'appelle
kubat sarah le dôme du rocher quel
rochet le rochais du sacrifice là où
abraham a mené et isaac ou ismaël une
deuxième tradition juive repris par
l'islam qu'au début du monde le lieu de
la jeunesse nous dit que le monde était
un petit but est due à séparer la terre
de l'eau et d'après la tradition le
première rochet qui a qui a émergé
séparer de l'ocse rochelle a donc ce
premier rocher sur lequel à partir
duquel commence la terre ferme
c'est cette pression juive reprise par
les musulmans aussi sur cet endroit donc
ses coups bas tels sarah ce qui est
important c'est le dôme du rocher le
rocher lors de la création du monde elle
reprochait du sacrifice d'abraham a fait
ici d'après la tradition le rocher c'est
l'endroit du saint des saints du temple
a été posée l'arche d'alliance avec
l'étape de la loi en sortant du bâtiment
vous rappeler qu'on a visités ja le
tabernacle plan du temps que les mêmes
faits tabernacle devant le l'entrée du
bâtiment il y avait le l'hôtel des
sacrifices et d'après la tradition le
là la terre avec laquelle du à chréa
dans la glaise former le premier homme
était prise l'endroit de l'hôtel est ce
que les sacrifices on paie pour
pardonner l'homme sachant que loeb a
fauté il a été créé de l'endroit que la
mana qui lui amène à
le pardon donc la glaise d'adam était
pris de l'endroit du de l'hôtel juste à
côté on va mettre devant en avant de
durocher qui est au centre du bâtiment
la ville à l'époque
pâque juive à l'époque romaine était
beaucoup plus grande que cette ville la
ville à l'époque turque dans sa as à
l'époque la moyenne avait dix mille
habitants au 19ème siècle l'arrivée
jusqu'à 20000 habitants la ville de
jérusalem aux premiers siècles compte
cent mille habitants c'est la cinquième
vente villes du monde elle est beaucoup
plus grande que ce qu'est le culot et
scary encerclé par les pas les murailles
on a reçu l'appel la troisième muraille
qui se trouve à plusieurs centimètres
plus au nord donc à l'époque après les
croisades à l'époque turque au xvième
siècle et turcs fortifie la ville
construise une muraille une muraille qui
n'a rien à voir que le tracé ancien de
la ville et c'est très important qu'à
chaque époque la ville change elle
muraille rouge comme ça on a pu
retrouver des murales différentes
époques jérusalem à plus de 4000 ans
d'existence on a retrouvé des murailles
turquie ya cinq siècles on a des
murailles de la croisade ya mille ans on
a des murailles de l'époque romaine il
ya deux mille ans de l'époque grecque et
2300 l'époque perse 2500 dépôt biblique
de 1700 et jusqu'à l'époque canal india
4000 ans ici sont passés tout et où tous
les peuples des cananéens les égyptiens
les rôles et les perses les romains les
et c'est toujours tout le monde
jusqu'aux sûr que jusqu aux anglais à
l'époque moderne et ce qui fait que
quand on voit des vestiges historiques
les vestiges archéologiques
c'est toujours très compliqué de s'en
sortir pour un touriste qui débarque
parce que on passe d'une époque à
l'autre et les époques
je suis père posé jeudi dans l'âme de la
muraille et c'est les murailles la
partie basse s'érode qu'elle a construit
les pires du basset d'hérode donc il ya
2001 et les parties sud c'était turcs y
compris maintenant les parties plus
clair c'est une réparation
jordanienne ya quelques années donc il
ya toutes les époques qui ce qui se
mélangent et j'oserais même est une
ville très complexe donc on voit la
vieille ville dans les villes il ya
quatre quartiers le quartier juif qui
est entre gauche voyait le dôme blanc
pense une synagogue le quartier musulman
qui a la droite devant nous avec les
mots ce qu'est le bâtiment plus
important c'est bien sûr le dôme du
rocher est le dôme doré en arrière plan
le quartier chrétien voyez les clochers
et le dôme gris
que ça sépulcre et d'après la pression
catholiques orthodoxes le togo le cdas
crucifixion et du thon rouge donc le
quartier chrétien qui se trouve là bas
et un quartier arménien qui est en
arrière donc ces quatre quartiers de la
vieille ville est ce que c'est important
chacun a son domaine dans le paysage
donc on voit un petit peu cette volonté
d'être présent dans le
dans le paysage
la porte qui est en face de nous dans un
mur avec une porte murée cette porte
s'appelle en hébreu charara même
l'apport de la miséricorde d'après une
tradition juive c'est par là donc le
messie qui vient du duo mondiaux va
rentrer dans jérusalem mais cette porte
a été muré par les musulmans pour
empêcher le messie des juifs de rentrée
c'est pour ça que la porte et murray est
devant au pied de la porte yahia
cimetière musulman même chose étant
donné qu' il ya une tradition qui dit
que provoque
le messie est précédé du prophète elie
qui est cohen il peut pas nous rentrer
dans un cimetière donc en bloquant la
porte et en même temps
un cimetière ça empêche l'arrivée du
messie juif à jérusalem elle est à peu
près à l'endroit à l'époque du temps
pierre une porte qui n'est pas à cet
endroit un peu décalé qui s'appelait la
porte de suse puisque de là on va vers
l'est et notre patron à l'époque quand
on revient de l'exil de babylonie c'est
l'époque de cyrus empereur de perth et
donc pour montrer notre loyauté à
l'empereur perse on avait appelé notre
porte la porte de suse qui était la
capitale des rois de perth
sur ce mont des oliviers dans l'appentis
un cimetière cimetière juif c'est le
cimetière juif le plus prisé du monde
parce que d'après une tradition que
l'histoire messianique commence le
messie arrimage aura également des
oliviers alors les premiers morts à se
lever la résurrection sont ceux qui sont
ici donc il y avait volonté d'être
enterré
et c'est au mont des oliviers la
question qui m'a été posée sont pas les
petites pierres quand on visite une
tombe on laisse une pierre pour dire on
était là beaucoup de symbolique dans la
pierre lapierre en hébreu se dit even
aveu ben le père le fils l'asuc cela
contre l'accumulation des générations et
surtout dans les temps anciens quand
chacun était satire c'est ça qui pesait
le monument funéraire sur la perse sur
la place versailles avait pas les
grandes pierres qu'on met aujourd'hui
ici sont des temps modernes qui est des
dernières années et plus on descend plus
et en plus ces anciens on arrive en bas
à des tombes via 2000 et des 3000 ans
une des tombes des monuments funéraires
des 3000 ans en bas pour des aigreurs
glyphes égyptien pourquoi une tombes
égyptiennes à jérusalem est donc les
archéologues veulent y voir la tombe de
la fille du pharaon la fille du pharaon
qui était l épouse de salomon
donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya une tombe ça
pour expliquer la présence d'une tombe
avec hiéroglyphes à jérusalem est datée
de 3000 ans
le monde y est j'ai dit il ya énormément
d'église quand jésus vient jérusalem y
vient pour la fête de pâques je suis
juif va donc faire le sacrifice pascal à
jérusalem au temple alors il ya déjà
expliqué que la ville comptait cent
mille habitants à la période de pâques
elle compte jusqu'à un million
d'habitants et donc on habite tout
autour là où on peut jésus arrive à
béthanie chez martell hasard bettany
c'est un village que ce serait juste sur
les pentes du mont des oliviers mais la
pente est de l'autre côté et donc c'est
la route qui fait quand il m'avait
autant que les quand il revient c'est
pour ça qu'on trouve ici l'endroit il a
pleuré l'endroit il enseigne aux cibles
dans le jardin du scanner où il a arrêté
c'est la route qu'empruntent jésus quand
il va de la maison de maître de béthanie
vers la vers la ville
et derrière le clocher de l'église de
l'ascension si on regarde dans la pente
voyez là le toit gris qui est sur un
endroit d'après la tradition une
tradition chrétienne jésus a pleuré
dominos les vides en dessous voyez le
dôme doré de les bulles dorées de
l'église russe orthodoxe l'église de
marie madeleine sur le site russe
orthodoxe de gsm jardin de gethsémani
jésus et arrêter si vous regardez plus
bas en contrebas vrai que les bus sont
garés dans la vallée c'est l'église
catholique de gethsémani donc je les ai
expliqué que c'est que l'église
catholique va dire c'est dans ce monde
dans ce jardin que jésus a arrêté les
rues d'hirson dans ce jardin même chose
avec l'église l'ascension y en a trois
donc les russes durant cet essai les
autres et autres trucs gens là elle est
catholique à côté on est dans le
périmètre personne ne peut mettre deux
doigts
préciser où les choses se sont passées
je rappelle que les trois premiers
siècles l'église chrétienne est une
église persécutée n'est pas légal pas
légitime dans le monde romain et à des
persécutions les chrétiens se cache
c'est uniquement à constantin que la
région de religion chrétienne a dominé
religion d'état donc les églises
pourraient être construites
allez un peu du mont des oliviers dans
les oliviers c'est un mot très spécial
et il est surtout mentionné dans le
livre du prophète zacharie au chapitre
xiv où il est question de la venue du
messie
et il est écrit que les plaies du messie
se poseront sur le mont des oliviers
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
le mont des oliviers est considérée
comme la montagne des choses dernière et
pourquoi y at il eu tellement de juifs
qui veulent être enterrés ici comme vous
le voyez ici le pont de montcy olivier
c'est un véritable cimetière énorme tout
simplement parce que comme ça été dit
tout à l'heure quand le messie viendra
il donnera le signal de la résurrection
des morts et on espère que plus on se
rapproche de l'endroit se produire à
l'événement plus de chance on aura d'y
participer
cette idée que du monde du nom iveco
montain des choses dernier qu'en
montagne de la résurrection vous la
retrouver dans le nouveau testament et
la première mention qu'on trouve en
relation avec ces choses derrière c'est
le le
la résurrection de lazare lazare un but
bête à nîmes et à nice et sur mon
arrivée mais sur l'autre pentes du mont
des oliviers et jésus va dire sur ce
monde est arrivé je suis la résurrection
et la vie
deuxième épisode c'est l'entrée de jésus
dans jérusalem jour des rameaux en tant
que messi jésus lui vient de jéricho est
donc en passant par bethanie et avait
après vente à l'iran il il monte sur la
non à betchat j'ai fait un petit peu
aussi à quelques distances de la le
lalanne contrairement à ce qu'on croit
snes et une monture royal s'était pas
l'entraînement un signe d'humilité c'est
plutôt une monture royal et 7 ans il
était blanc parce que l'un du mi6 sera
forcément un âne blanc après avoir ainsi
palais jésus marchait devant la foule
pour monter à jérusalem lorsqu'il
approchera de bethphagé de béthanie vers
la montagne à peu les montagnes des
olives et jésus envoyé à deux de ses
disciples en disant allez au village qui
est en face quand vous irez entrée vous
trouvez un anneau attaché sur lequel
aucun homme ne s'est jamais assis
détacher de amené le mois c'est
quelqu'un vous demande pourquoi le
détacher vous me répondrez le seigneur
en a besoin ceux qui avaient été envoyés
à l'air et rouvert les choses comme
jésus leur avait dit comme il est à
celle annoncée mais tu nous dire
pourquoi détachées vous danon
répondirent le seigneur en a besoin les
amenèrent à jésus la non sur lequel
jeter à l'eau vêtements et fait remonter
jésus quand il fut en marche des gens et
en dire le revêtement sur le chemin et
lorsque déjà et l'approché du jury elle
aime faire la descente du mont des
oliviers
toute la multitude illicites saisie de
joie se mit à louer dieu à haute voix
pour tous l'émirat qu'ils avaient
utilisé béni soit le roi qui vient au
nom du seigneur tiré du psaume 118 p
dans le ciel et gloire dans les lieux
très haut quelques parisiens du milieu
de la foudre et à jésus maître prend tes
disciples mais bon je vous le dis si ce
test ses plaies au cuir ont
comme est approché la ville jésus en la
voyant plus rassure elle est il dit
aussi au moins ce jour qui était donnée
tuque si tu venais c'est des choses qui
appartiennent à taper le matin se cacher
à tes yeux
et là il annonça de ruzhou zalem mais
rassure-toi des joutes et demi environ
de toutes parts tant ces fonds est
enfermeront et écriront toi et tes
enfants milieu de toi ils ne seront pas
en toi cher sur pierre parce que tu n'as
pas connu le temps que tu as été visités
donc ça c'est le deuxième épisode sur le
mont des oliviers jésus descend du mont
des oliviers pour entrer dans jérusalem
est là il va chasser les marchands du
temple à la suite de cette entrée dans
jérusalem troisième épisode quelques
jours après jésus donc enseigne dans le
temple et il se réfugie le soir et fait
du camping sauvage qui ont vu en bas
donc dans un des jardins qui se trouve
près du mont des oliviers parce que le
monde y arriver comme son indic c'est un
moment qu'on cultive des oliviers alors
qu'on vient à saison des olives les
olives est son goal et et puis elles
descendent le long de la pente par
gravitation et en bas elle se récupérer
et précédent des pressoirs à huile à
vide ou le jardin de gethsémané gatx
m'anime le pressoir à olive on a deux
tours de très nombreux prêts soit au
livre qui date de cette période là alors
dire que c'est ce jardin avoue sud à
côté ça c'est un autre problème mais
disons ses danseuses dans ces régions là
qu'un lieu ce cet épisode est chez
fusion que
allégeant le temps pensé de la journée
il rentrait le soir au mont des oliviers
et un jour qui sortait du temple disent
ils lui ont fait remarquer les belles
pierres du temple jésus après a donné
une prophétie sur la rue de jérusalem
comme l'avait fait tant d'autres
prophètes avant lui et les disciples lui
demande seniors qu'elle sera lucile de
ces événements de ton retour et de la
fin du monde jésus monde sur le mont des
oliviers et sur le mont des oliviers que
le monde ait des choses dernière il
donne les discours apocalyptiques qui
sera portée dans le chapitre 24 de
matthieu 13 de marque et 21 de l'udc
donc le discours sur la fin des temps le
grand discours sur la fin des tours
montre ici une grotte dans laquelle
jésus aurait prononcé ce discours la fin
des temps c'est peu probable qu'il ait
fait dans une grotte parce qu'au
contraire ils voulaient avoir la vue sur
la jérusalem ici qui devait connaître
cette prune et en même temps cette
résurrection à la fin des temps puisque
il prophétisé de choses et puis enfin
dernier point jésus donc après la
résurrection va monter sur le mont des
oliviers avec ses disciples et c'est là
qu'il va remonter au ciel comme nous le
trouvons dans le livre des actes et je
voudrais vous lui aussi ce texte comme
il se trouvait avec eux il recommanda de
se passer données du jerusalem maisa
temps ce que le père avait promu ce que
je vous ai annoncé dans dit il car jean
baptiste dans l'eau mais vous en peu de
temps vous serez baptisé dans le
saint-esprit alors les apôtres et lui
demandèrent seigneur est sûre ces temps
là que tu juan tu rétablir à le royaume
d'israël
jésus leur répondit ce n'est pas à vous
de connaître les temps et les moments
que paie à fixer de sa propre autorité
entre parenthèses jésus nous dit pas
qu'il ne rétablira pas le royaume
d'israël qui dit simplement que ce n'est
pas le moment encore mais vous recevrez
une puissance de saint-esprit survenant
sur vous et vous serez mes témoins à
jérusalem dans toute la judée dans la
samarie et jusqu'aux extrémités de la
terre
nous avons dit cela il fut élevé pendant
qu'il regardait et une nuée que des
robes à leurs yeux ce qu'elle fait pas
par ici
et comme il savait le regard fixé vers
le ciel pendant qu'il s'en allait voici
deux ans vêtu de blanc leur a paru de
dirhams galilea pourquoi vous arrêtez
vous à regarder le ciel ce jésus qu'a
été enlevés au ciel du milieu de vous
viendra de la même manière que prévu
venant ciel pourquoi l'enlèvement
l'ascension a été levée sur le monde est
élevé parce que ce sera l'endroit aussi
du retour alors ils retournèrent ajouté
wallemme depuis la montagne appelé
montagne des oliviers près de jérusalem
à la distance des chemins de shabbat ils
ont dû foot aviv est monté dans la
chambre haute où si c'était des
d'ordinaire c'était pierre jean jacques
andré philippe thomas barthélémy mathieu
jacques final fait simon le zélote et
judas fils jack tous d'un commun accord
personne n'a pris avec les femmes m
arrive de perdre une mère de jésus est
avec les frères de jésus
alors ici on est dans un un un jardin
qui est donné par les latins comme étant
le jardin de gethsémané
celui là où c'est un autre on peut pas
savoir évidemment l'emplacement exact
dans la mesure où le mont des oliviers
c'est très c'est très long
combat de du mont des oliviers il y
avait de très nombreux jardins et
notamment avec des pressions à rouler
mieux s'arrêter là parce que si on a un
ancien pressoir donc
on a une idée de ce que ça pouvait être
être à l'époque
mais je voudrais donc lire ici le récit
de ce qui s'est passé dans un de ses
jardins là si ce n'est celui là c'est
celui d'à côté ou un autre mais enfin
disons c'est dans cette région là quoi
qu'il en soit que des choses se sont
produites
lorsque je dis ces choses jésus à la
avec ses dix sites de l'autre côté du
torrent du céderont où se trouvait un
jardin est à noter que jean est le seul
des quatre évangélistes à ne pas
préciser que ce jardin simplifiée de ses
manet gatx m'anime c'est à dire le
pressoir à olive
donc un jardin il entre à lui et ses
disciples
judas qui le livret connaissez ce lieu
parce que jésus et ses disciples est ici
était souvent réunit donc c'était à peu
près l'endroit où jésus se rassembler
avec ses disciples pour faire du camping
sauvage comme on disait judas donc et
offrit avec lui laporte et des musiques
arrivée qui envoyait les principaux
sacrificateurs et les pharisiens peu
avec des dentaire des flambeaux est déjà
très intéressant de noter que jean est
le seul à nous mentionner le fait que
parmi ceux qui sont venus arrêter jésus
qui étaient les gardes du temps donc
faire la solde des sadducéens des grands
prêtres il y avait des romains l'accorte
la corse et la cort c'était quelque
chose d'évident de très important dans
la mesure où ça nous montre à quel point
les romains étaient impliqués dans le
l'arrestation et le procès de jésus
comme on a vu
jésus sachant ce qui devait lui arriver
ça avance a indiqué chez vous ils
répondirent jésus nazareth où jésus leur
dit c'est moi
judas qu'une buvette avec lui parce
qu'ils lui dis cela
parce que jésus lui dit c'est moi ils
reculent air est tombé par terre leurs
demandes à nouveau qui cherchez vous ai
dit jésus de nazareth jésus répondit je
vous le dis que c'est moi qu'ils ont
c'est moi que vous cherchez
laisser-aller ceci dit cela afin que
s'accomplisse la parole de ceux qui
parlent qui avait été dit je n'ai perdu
aucun de ceux que tu m'as donné simon
pierre qui avait une épée la tirah fera
pas de sacrificateurs dû souvent
sacrificateurs et du coup pas l'oreille
droite serviteur s'appelait malchus
jésuites à pieve remettons d'épée dans
le four n'aurais-je pas la coupe que le
père m'a donné de bois la cohorte à
nouveau la mention d'accord tu es encore
un autre détail extrêmement important le
tribun ça veut dire que toute
l'opération d'arrestation de jésus était
dirigée par un tribun un tribun c'est un
officier supérieur de l'armée de l'armée
romaine c'est l'équivalent d'un colonel
ou d'un lieutenant-colonel vous imaginez
un colonel
déplacer pour aller arrêter un simple
prévenu c'est que les romains devait
avoir une sacrée frousse de jésus
et il avait des pneus déployer des
forces importantes et s'attendait à une
résistance très forte de la part de
celui qui les imaginent être un
agitateur politique
et voilà donc les échelons les choses se
passent donc il se saisir de jésus
leudière d'amener d'abord chez rahman et
chez son beau-frère crif qui était
souvent sans les créateurs cette année
là donc voilà ici le récit de
l'arrestation de jésus un autre texte en
vue que cette fois ci après être sortie
il assure sa coutume la montagne des
oliviers ses disciples suivi parce que
fumer dans sa vie et leur dis prie afin
que vous ne tombez pas en tentation puis
s'éloigne à 2 à 10 ans environ jets de
pierres et s'étant mis à genoux en
principe là enfin bon ça c'est tout à
fait fantaisistes il est il disait père
si tu voulais éloigné de moi cette coupe
toutefois non pas que ma volonté se
fasse mais la tienne
alors un enjeu apparu du ciel faut le
fortifier est en agonie brillait plus
instamment et s'assure de 20 comme des
grumeaux de sang qui tombait par terre
après avoir prié il se leva et 20 et 10
6 plus trouver endormie de tristesse je
leur dis pourquoi dormez vous lever vous
privé afin que vous ne trouviez pas aux
tentations et après c'est le récit de
l'arrestation selon l'udc qui rejoint à
peu près ce que nous avons vu tout à
l'heure dans gens alors
qu'il ya une une tradition dans le
judaïsme qui dit que quand l'olivaie
pressel pl l'huile ce sont les larmes de
l'olivier
elle est pressée donc pour pouvoir
exprimer son jus
et bien de la même manière donc terre
l'olivier c'est un arbre qui symbolise
lui met la lumière la lumière c'est le
messie faut donner sa lumière l'olive
doit être broyés et d'une certaine
manière ici jésus a été broyée sous le
poids de l'angoissent qu'on la lui tout
à l'heure et par conséquence cessé de
par cette agonie qu'il a vécu ici qui
était un véritable broyage
qui n'a pu donc être celui qui a réalisé
de la rédemption
outre l'attrait de l'argent mais ce
n'était pas une femme extraordinaire il
avait touché à cet endroit donc j'avais
d'autres motivations et les motivations
c'était bon chic période c'était un vil
donc été
réputée pour être une ville de zélotes
et
judas devait d'appartenir à la secte des
zélotes c'est à dire ceux qui croyaient
à l'établissement du royaume de dieu par
la force par les armes et voyons que
jésus n'accomplissait pas le programme
messianique tel qu'il l'entendait il a
innové
ça c'est une hypothèse il aurait tenté
de le contraindre quelque sorte à sortir
de son de sa réserve en le mettant dans
une situation vous ne risquez d'être
l'arrestation et la mort il imaginait qu
à ce moment là j'ai pleuré ses pouvoirs
nation naturelle pour échapper à bord à
son sort et deuxièmement pour établir le
royaume de dieu telle que tel que vous
ne concevez et quand il a vu que jésus
se laisser arrêter que jésus
n'intervenez pas qu'eux mêmes ils à
illéla d'ordonner à pierre de remettre
son époux dans le flou
il a il a compris qu'il y avait rien
attendre et que par conséquent cela
qu'il est tombé dans le désespoir et il
a conduit au suicide
il fallait un traître parce qu'autrement
jésus aurait était introuvable donc il
fallait un traître il fallait quelqu'un
qui soit dans de tout proche jésus un
intime de jésus qui connaît ses
habitudes et donc judas a été celui qui
vivent avec la société tous à coup plus
fluide a été celui qui a compris ça mais
comme dit jésus pour seul malheur à
celui là il vaudrait mieux que ne soit
jamais né
tout ce quartier que loyer est construit
sur pilotis et rentrer sous nos pieds se
trouve la ville il ya 2000 ans alors ce
pâté de maison on a retrouvé non
seulement la ville de milan mais le
quartier de la rixe progresser les
sadducéens les prêtres du temple et donc
on peut voir comment vivent et les
prêtres l'aristocratie celles du cn il y
a deux mille ans
aqua sait-on combien d'hommes léry
stockera c'est d'abord la taille des
maisons
ensuite des parterres mosaïque
évidemment les gens des gens simples non
pas des mosaïques et dans le salon salle
à manger surtout debout avec vous cette
qualité il ya celle d'allemagne à une
baignoire et à côté un rituel privé
derrière il ya le bassin damas rituel
privé vous que c'est quelqu'un qui a
dans sa maison non seulement des
parterres en mosaïque mais qui a une
baignoire tout on n'a pas de baignoire à
l'époque encore moins de bains rituels
privée donc on est dans l'aristocratie
du temple
ça lui sert les prêtres du temple qui
vivent à la romaine et qui viennent
façon très opulente
voilà quelque chose de très bizarres des
verts en pierre
vous comprenez que si faire un verre
comme ça on peut s'apprendre ça prend
cinq minutes pour un artisan qui sait
bien travailler faire un verre de pierre
comme ça c'est des heures de travail et
faire un arrondi comme ça quand on
travaille au burin et c'est encore plus
compliqué et donc ces cesu stensil coûte
très cher
alors pourquoi des ustensiles en pierres
ça ça on arrive à un problème de pureté
rituelle
se sont parlé du mikvé du fed allait se
purifier et se tremper un vsr une
vaisselle dans laquelle et des aliments
et qui est touché par quelqu'un d'un pur
des aliments deviennent un pur
or d'après la loi juive quand un aliment
sur trois ans vit dans un b c'est
jean-pierre elle transmet pas l'aspect
l'impureté
pour des gens qui quittent dont ne
travaillait au temple qui mangent les
dim qui mangent les sacrifices qu'ils
mangent des choses pure qui doivent même
être en état de pureté ils ont tout le
temps se plonger dans le mikvé sa règle
un problème si jamais je n'ai pas besoin
de l'attention qui a touché qui est
passée par là et ce qui est par exemple
par hasard un serviteur une servante en
état d'alerté qui a touché la vaisselle
ça ne rend pas un pur les mets qui sont
dedans et donc quand on trouve ces
récipients on sait que l'on demeure qui
appartiennent à l'aristocratie du temple
auprès du temple il ya que eux qui
étaient prêts à investir tellement
d'argent dans une vaisselle de ce type
là donc quand on trouve cette vaisselle
dans ces maisons qu'on a trouvé on a un
indice de plus le fait d'abord le mikvé
et d'avoir ces baies celles de pierre
est une fois une preuve qu'on est dans
des gens qui font très attention à la
pureté comme on est juste à côté du
temple 1 + 1 on est dans les maisons des
prêtres du temple
c'est très intéressant parce que vous
trouvez que ça dans l'évangile de jean
nous sommes une histoire des noces de
cana nous ait dit qu'il y avait six
vases de pierre ses ventes purification
cerveau purification donc en relation
avec la pureté comme cvn sa vie nous est
expliqué et ça c'est un indice très
important parce que ça veut dire que
l'auteur de l'évangile de jean
connaissait parfaitement ses rites le
pluri de pureté de ses outils de
vaisselle en clair et par conséquent
vivait à l'époque où le temple exister
parce qu'après comme le temps pas été
détruit on a oublié tous ces règles là
et on a oublié le
même le fait que l'on avait fait sept
cette vie celle de ceux de celle de
pierre par conséquent c'est un indice de
caractère antique de l'évangile de jean
ici nous sommes dans un jeu très
important pour le nouveau testament vous
avez ici deux structures une supérieure
et une inférieure qui sont en
décalage donc en dénivelé
vous aviez en plus de ça ici une rue qui
était extérieur pas avec les escaliers
qu'on a descendu la et vous avez une rue
parallèle qui était de l'autre côté on
sait par l'historien juif flavius
josèphe que hérode quand il a épousé la
fille du dernier grand prêtre à ce
moulin a fait à son beau père le don
d'une soupe d'un superbe palais qui se
trouvaient dans la partie est de
jérusalem donc dans la région dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons et
par la suite quand
le grand prêtre a été assassiné les des
as monnaies ont été assassinés ont
disparu
le
ballet de des as moulins est devenu le
palais de la résidence des grands
prêtres
je vous ai expliqué que à l'époque
romaine des grands prêtres étaient
changés tous les 4-5 ans à peu près
j'étais déposer un autre prenez la place
il y avait donc plusieurs familles de
près téva bill et béate hausse les rames
année de 4 ans qui se dit qui se
partageaient la grande prêtrise
et
si vous aviez donc le palais des grands
prêtres on est à peu près certain que ça
c'était le palais des grands traite
comment le sait-on à cause de ces de la
salle dans laquelle nous sommes ici et
c'était une immense salle
avec une antichambre qui est ici et qui
manifestement été la salle d'audience
dans laquelle le grand prêtre
intervenait et l'idée d'une chercheuse
française qui s'appelle madame je m'aime
je loue bismuth malheureusement décédé
vous maintenant
nous explique que c'est est ici que
jallieu le procès de jésus devant le
grand prêtre
voilà nous sommes ici exactement dans
cet endroit alors ici vous pouvez vous
représenter la scène on va là lire tel
que les rapportés par jean jean qui
était un homme qui était lui-même
vraisemblablement d'une famille de
prêtres subalternes et il avait donc des
accointances avec le grand prêtre et
nous allons venir justement à la suite
du récit que nous avons lu tout à
l'heure quand nous étions dans le jardin
de gethsémané
l'accord le tribun est vicié des juifs
se saisir alors de jésus et le lierre et
l'emmenèrent d'abord chez annan qui
était le beau-père de caïphe qui était
un souverain sacrificateur cette année
là puisque comme je vous l'expliquais
les grands prêtres étaient constamment
changer anna donc habiter c'est triste
cette partie ci
tandis que khalifa but est de la partie
basse
de cet ensemble ce qui fait que vous
voyez il était très facile de passer
d'une demeure à l'autre et il y avait un
va et vient qui s'est produit entre
chanas des qualifs
adan a procédé à un interrogatoire
préliminaire de jésus et puis ensuite il
a traduit devant son gendre qui était
khalife qui séduit l'a reçu dans cette
salle ici cette salle du 3 e ici nous
avions le
le corps de garde et une cour ici une
cour extérieure où les gars se tenait
pendant qu'on jugeait les prisonniers on
verra tout à l'heure l'importance de ce
lieu donc qualif était celui qui avait
donné ce conseil et cetera il est
avantageux qu'un seul homme pour up
simon-pierre avec un autre disciple
suivaient jésus se dissipe était connue
du souverain sacrificateur élantra avec
jésus dans la cour du souverain
sacrificateur
là bas donc il est descendu par là il
est l'approché cette antichambre là et
il est allé dans la cour rabat
mais pierre et des restes à dehors près
de la porte ici
l'autre disciples étaient connus du
souverain sacrificateur
sortie par la portière il fit rentrer
pierre alors la servante 10 à la porte
de l ac avant d'apporter aide et à pied
tu as aussi ne tue pas parmi les
disciples de cet homme il dit je n'en
suis pas
serviteur et les musiques étaient là
avaient allumé un brasier car il faisait
froid c'était à l'époque de pâques il
faut croire qu'à jérusalem donc là le
brasier avait été allumé la danse est
que vous voyez là
et ils se chauffaient claire se tenait
avec eux et se chauffer sur un
sacrificateur elle a interrogé à jésus
et ses disciples sur sa doctrine jésus
lui répondit gpal ouvertement monde je
joue en série à synagogue et dans le
temple où tous les juifs s'assemble je
n'ai rien fait en secret pourquoi
interroge tu interroges ce que je leur
ai dit et qui m'ont entendu voici ceux
là savent ce que j'ai dit ac - des
huissiers qui se trouvait là lui donne
un souffle et en dix ans et ceux ci que
tu réponds souvent sacrificateur je lui
dis si j'ai mal parlé explique moi en
quoi je dis du mal j'ai bien paré
pourquoi me feras tu
annan l'envoya lié à cai et fu souverain
sacrificateur simon pierre était là il
se chauffe et on lui dit tu as aussi
n'es tu pas de ses disciples il lui a il
dit je ne suis pas donc premier
interrogatoire préliminaire chez keith
sherin a ici et ensuite jésus descend là
pendant que claire est en train de
s'échauffer
un déçu des serviteurs du souverain
sacrificateur parents de celui à qui pue
pierre avait coupé une oreille dit je
t'ai vu dans le jardin toi aussi pierre
le nuit à nouveau et aussitôt le coq
chante a
alors vous pouvez vous représenter la
scène
quand après donc le procès religieux
jésus va être transféré devant le
gouverneur romain pilate qui va donc
confirmé la sentence
ils sont par ici ou par là
et pierre sueur par là
ils se croisent ici
n'est pas un mot des changes et
met lé regard candide nom
et pierre comprend ce qui lui est arrivé
et il pleure amèrement
si vous pouvez vous représenter
exactement cette scène
alors bienvenue au mont sion si vous
regardez le bâtiment voyez qu'on
apparemment dans la cour d'un cluster
d'un cloître chrétiens sans être
archéologue vous verrez que le mur
devant vous composée de plusieurs partis
il ya un mur du bas avec des grandes
pierres une partie haute que les pierres
plus petit on est en bas des fenêtres
carrées rectangulaires on en haut des
fenêtres
en arche en ogive on a deux bâtiments
superposé ici en fait 3 on a d'abord en
bas un bâtiment qui est une synagogue
parce que c'est l'endroit où la
tradition juive voit le taux mots de
david donc c'est une synagogue la partie
supérieure c'est déjà gothique c'est une
chapelle c'est la tradition chrétienne
voit le cénacle le dernier repas de
jésus et la chambre haute où jésus va
réapparaître aux apôtres après la
crucifixion donc c'est une chapelle
chrétienne donc on a une synagogue et
une chapelle qu'est ce qu'on a au dessus
un minaret et tout le bâtiment en fait
est transformée en mosquée alors qu'est
ce qui se passe après la croisade
arrivent les mêmes luc et il ya un
différend entre les juifs qui ont ainsi
négocié et les craintes les chrétiens
qu'on la chapelle au dessus à qui
appartient le bâtiment quand il est
différent on arrive au tribunal le
tribunal ce tribunal musulman on à
l'époque même l'udc et
le
le caddie le jugement va demander aux
juifs c'est quoi ils vont dire ça c'est
le tombeau du roi david
sénat ben hida août des écritures oui à
certains quelqu'un de sain puisque les
musulmans reconnaissent aussi là
la bible ancien testament nouveau
testament comme texte révélé le texte
ultime c'est le coran mais il ya une
valeur aussi à la ville de givet et aux
évangiles ce sont des textes saints et
les gens qui sont dans son habit
prophète il demande aux chrétiens ce qui
alors ibis et la scène c'est jésus nabil
chaas donc ccnb saad oui oui c'est lui
est alors le caddie va rendre le
jugement suivant si senna bidaou de nabi
ça c'est encore lieu saint musulman donc
vous les jouez vous partez vous les
écrêtés avoue décamper ont fait mosquée
et le bâtiment est transformée en
mosquée pendant les prochains siècles
viens nous nous trouvons ici dans un des
lieux les plus à tester au point de vue
authenticité donc ici c'est la chambre
l'autre ou trois événements
de l'évangile se sont accomplis le
premier c'est le dernier repas que jésus
est pris avec ses disciples donc la
dernière scène la pac n'a pas qu'il a
mangé avant sa passion avance avant ses
souffrances le deuxième événement c'est
lorsqu'il est apparu vivant à ses
disciples ressusciter le soir de pâques
toutes les portes de ce lieu était fermé
et donc jésus est apparu
à ses disciples ressuscité dans ce lieu
là et troisièmement c'est là que 40
jours plus tard le saint-esprit est
descendu sur les apôtres ou le jour de
la pentecôte donc et de la l'évangile
s'est répandu sur toute la surface de la
terre ces raisons pour laquelle
on appelle ces traits 7,7 s'étendre la
matière et crise y est ça veut dire la
mère des églises toutes les églises
puisque c'est là que la première église
a été créé
pour vous allez me dire
c'est pas très exotique en quelque sorte
ici sarsan que vous le voyez il ya deux
styles qui sont qui sont entrecroisées
d'une part vous avez ici la voûte vival
croisés et puis ensuite vous avez ici
une niche de prière qui typiquement
musulmane ainsi que la chair là-bas à
partir de laquelle se faisait les
prédications dans la dans les mosquées
donc c'est plus un endroit qui a été à
la fois une église
croisés et puis ensuite une mosquée
alors c'est vrai que tout ne s'ouvrira
n'est pas authentique mais l'emplacement
est authentique c'est ça qui est
important comment le savons nous et bien
parce que
il y a 6 à bord dont 10 dans ce qu'on
appelle une cata l'uma en grec quant à
l'huma c'est à dire un caravansérail
vous avez vu il ya deux étages s'était
dit fils là il ya le bas où se trouve le
tombeau david nous étions et un instant
et puis vous avez ici la partie de la
partie supérieure
catane uma c'est exactement le move est
employé pour désigner le l'auberge de
bethléem dans laquelle jésus est né
contrairement à la tradition jésus n'est
pas dans une grotte mais il est né dans
une chapelle une hôtellerie une de khat
alluma une hôtellerie c'est un édifice à
deux étages c'est ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui un caravansérail jusqu'au
19ème siècle c'était encore d'aider des
édifices de ce type qui étaient utilisés
pour les voyageurs et pour les caravanes
donc deux niveaux un niveau inférieur et
un niveau supérieur et le niveau
supérieur s'appelle la chambre haute
vive hausse inférieure la chambre basse
et le niveau suivant la chambre haute la
chambre basse et est utilisé pour
remiser les animaux ont voyagé sur des
animaux essentiellement sur des âmes et
chameaux c'était déjà du super luxe mais
là n'était la monture la plus courante
le cheval un peu moins et l'autre noté
dry de bethléem était construite
exactement sur le même plan que celui ci
donc on ne misait les animaux en bas et
les bipèdes les les êtres humains loger
ici à l'étagé supérieur c'est-à-dire un
sauna pts et la chambre haute ces
chambres d'hôtes vous avez vous voyez
c'était une salle commune et là ils
avaient des tables sur lesquelles on
mangeait on pas ne relève pas et que les
repas étaient terminées ont tiré des
tables ont dérangé contre les murs et
chacun déployer sa natte et ont couché
tous comme ça alignés les uns à côté des
autres
et lorsque jésus est né à bethléem
là le caravansérail en question était
surpeuplé puisque c'était ce buzz une
petite ville mais c'était l'époque du
recensement et il était nécessaire que
chaque recensé aille dans sa ville
natale grave in manhattan en tout cas de
ce2 de ces de ses ancêtres et tout ce
qui était de la famille de david donc
devait venir à bethléem
si bien que pour le recensement le petit
caravansérail de bethléem était
absolument surpeuplées et marie a été
prise de douleurs de l'accouchement
juste alors qu'il se trouvait dans cette
chambre haute
évidemment
elle a préféré descendre en bas avec les
animaux
pour avoir un peu plus d'intimité que
milieu de toute cette foule de gens qui
je voulais que tu l'as dans la chambre
haute si bien que l'imagerie de bethléem
qui nous présente un toit pentu
roth et sert à ça c'est absolument une
authentique et aussi l'imagerie d'epinal
qui nous montre jésus entre le
le boeuf et l'âne lan d'accord oui pour
lan non pour le boeuf pour une raison et
vous voyez on ne voyage pas sauter au
début évident entre parenthèses notons
que la mettait aussi un animal de luxe
et
seuls les riches pouvaient se payer un
halde et l'imagerie d'epinal aussi qui
nous montre marie monté sur l'année
joseph qui tire lane ont tout ça sur des
cartes postales de noël c'est une
authentique marie joseph était trop
pauvre pouvoir se payer un âne et il
voyage et appelé tout simplement
donc ici je reviens à d'autres à notre
catane uma et 6 2
de télévente et voici ce que nous disons
dans l'évangile de marc angers angers de
l'ufa non
le joug des pinceaux le vin ou deux
nounous devait être immolés la pâques
arrive à jésus ouvrier appelé région
disant allez nous préparer la pac afin
que nous ne mangions il veut dire où
veux tu nous l'as préparions il répondit
va c'est quand vous serez en train de la
ville vous rencontrerez un homme portant
une cruche d'eau nous avons vu que un
homme qui portait d'une souche dos est
pas habituel parce que la corvée d'eau
c'est le travail des femmes donc ici
s'agissait d'un d'un homme qui n'avait
pas de femmes qui étaient donc
anesthésiant est ici on est à fond dans
le quartier saignant suis venu dans la
maison ou de ventre et vous livrer au
maître de la maison le maître te dis ou
et le vieux où je mangerai la pac avec
mes disciples il vous montrera une
grande chambre et auprès haute alors
meublé en fait le texte grec diène avec
trois coussins
ça veut dire ce qu'on appelle la nasa un
triclinium c'est à dire un endroit où il
y avait des tables qui était en forme de
u comme ça et les tables basses vous
connaissez tous la fameuse le fameux
tableau de léonard de vinci quai sur la
dernière scène où l'on voit jésus
habillé d'ailleurs avec ses disciples en
costumes de l'époque on est à fond dans
la crau 10 mhz total est assis à table
ses disciples de chaque côté il est au
centre de la table et ses disciples
santé de chaque côté en réalité jésus
n'était pas assis à table il était
couché à table c'était une table basse
comme chez les grands c'est dur romain
et
on était couchés allongés sur des
coussins d'où l'expression une chambre
et autres me
garni de trois coussins donc trois
coussins parce que il y avait trois
tables en forme de u c'est là que vous
préparez la pâte ils partirent être
ouverts les choses cumulent leur avait
dit et préparer à la park
l'heure est venue se met à table et
apôtres avec lui il a dit j'ai désiré
vivement manger cette pac avec vous
avant de souffrir car je vous dis je
n'en mangerai plus jusqu'à ses soit
accomplir le royaume de dieu et en prix
une coupe du grath dit prenez cette
coupe est distribuée d'entre vous je
vous le dis je ne boirai plus désormais
du fruit de la vigne jusqu'à ce que deux
royaumes de dieu soit venu ensuite il
prix du pain après avoir dû grâce il
rompit leur donna en disant ceci est mon
corps est donné pour vous faites cesser
mémoire de moi il prêt de même la coupe
après le souper à leur donnant dix ans
ses troupes et la nouvelle alliance en
mon sens qu il répondu pour vous on va
dire un autre texte où il est question
de l'apparition ici dans la chambre
haute après la résurrection pendant
qu'il parlait de la sorte c'est à dire
les disciples d'emmaüs qui était
retourné après la révélation de jésus
ressuscité
tandis qu'il parlait de la sorte lui
même se présente un milieu et le redis
la paix soit avec vous saisie de frayeur
et épouvante il croyait voir un esprit
si l'on dit pourquoi êtes-vous trouble
et pourquoi pas répond c'est s'élève tel
de vos coeurs voyez mes mains et mes
pieds c'est bien moi tout chez moi voyez
un esprit lundi cheikh news que vous
voyez que j'ai et en en disant cela il
remontera ses mains ses pieds comme dans
l'argent et ne croyaient pas encore
qu'ils étaient 2 il était dans
l'étonnement et de redire avez vous
quelque chose à manger vu présenter du
poisson retirer ou de miel et il mange à
deux vantaux plusieurs dit c'est là ce
que je vous disais juste et avec vous il
fallait que ça complique tout ce qui est
écrit deux mois tu auras brise dans les
prophètes et dans les psaumes alors il
leur ouvrir l'esprit afin qu'ils
comprennent les écritures et puis un
dernier texte dans le chapitre 2 du
livre des actes donc le troisième
événement qui s'est produit dans ce lieu
joua à pentecôte ils étaient tous
ensemble dans le même dieu tout à coup
il va du ciel comme un bruit comme celui
d'un vent impétueux il remplit toute la
maison dans lequel il était assis des
langues sont d'avis et langues de feu
leur a paru séparées les unes des autres
et se poser sur chacun d'eux ils furent
tous remplis du saint-esprit et se mit à
parler en d'autres langues selon que
l'esprit de redonner de s'exprimer il y
avait un séjour à jérusalem des juifs au
monsieur de toutes les nations qui sont
sous le ciel avoué qu'il vieux la
multitude à coup vu et fut confondues
parce que chacun y entendez parler dans
sa propre langue ils étaient tous dans
l'étonnement et la surprise et se
disaient les uns les autres voici ces
gens qui parlent ne sont ils pas tous
galilea et comment nous entendons nous
parler notre langue a chacun notre
langue maternelle par mais dynamite ce
qu'ils avaient dit ravi de la
mésopotamie la judée la cappadoce notons
la cie la phrygie la profit de l'égypte
le territoire de l'as de la libye
voisine de sirène ceux qui sont venus de
rome juifs et prosélyte crétois et
arabes comment les entendons nous parler
dans notre langue des merveilles de dieu
ils étaient tous dans l'étonnement de
sachant que pense et se disaient les uns
aux autres que veut dire cela mais
d'autres se moque heures 10 ans sont
plates vendent ou alors pierre se
présenta devant eux et ne va la voix et
leur parle en ces termes homme juif et
vous tous qui séjournent et à jérusalem
sachez ceci est prêté de rien mais
parole ces gens ne sont pas idiots comme
vous le supposez mais c'est la troisième
heure du jour mais c'est ici ce qui a
été annoncé par le prophète joël
parisien détendu dieu je répondrais mon
esprit surtout de shell au fils et vos
filles prophétisant aux jeunes gens ont
des visions taisez vous hier et nous
avons des songes
alors comment peut-on être sûr que le
lieu dans lequel nous nous trouvons et
ce lieu qui a été évoqué dans ces trois
lectures rien parce que nous avons une
tradition qui remonte très loin d'abord
j'ai dit tout à l'heure nous sommes ici
dans le quartier seigneur
et
là il y a eu donc des relations entre
jésus et le propriétaire du duc était un
enseignant avaient donc ici qui était
propriétaire de cette auberge de cette
cata l'huma de ce caravansérail qui se
trouvait à ceux à cet endroit là ce qui
est intéressant c'est de noter que ce
lieu est devenu le lieu de rassemblement
de la première communauté de jérusalem
donc la première église la mère de
toutes les églises se trouvait ici à
partir du 4e siècle
à partir de là la conversion de
constantin christianisme ce lieu devient
le saint et tous les pèlerins qui
viennent à jérusalem le visite
nous avons des récits de voyage des
pèlerins des premiers siècles à partir
du 4e siècle jusqu'à la conquête arabe
et il ya deux grandes époques à partir
de 7,2 ce temps là une première époque
va du quatrième ou cinquième siècle
environ où tous les visiteurs qui
viennent en pèlerinage jérusalem tous
les pèlerins visitent ce qui s'appelle
justement la mère de toutes les églises
mater ecclesiae
et ils nous disent que dans ce lieu il y
avait une communauté judéo chrétienne
qui se réclamait de jacques le frère de
jésus
d'ailleurs
il ya encore reçu une tradition qui
feront monter ce duel à ajac on est ici
dans le quartier arménien de la vieille
ville aujourd'hui qui dépend du
monastère de saint jacques du patriarcat
de saint jacques parce que les arméniens
se considèrent comme les héritiers de la
première communauté qui se trouvait ici
à jérusalem une communauté judéo
chrétienne qui était de langue hébraïque
qui lisait le nouveau testament en
hébreu qui priaient en hébreu qui
faisait ses services en hébreu est
apparemment pour les premiers qu'être
les premiers pèlerins chrétiens ça ne
poser aucun problème
à partir du vème siècle jusqu'à la
conquête arabe ça ça change les pèlerins
évoque le fait qu'il existe ici une
communauté judéo chrétienne mais c'est
julien aucune communauté
judéo-chrétienne hérétiques
pourquoi parce que elle et julien
hoferlin guerre du shabbat il vient les
fêtes ils ont la torah il continua à
trier en hébreu
quelle horreur quelle abomination
donc ce sont des hérétiques ils sont
excommuniés et le l'église judéo
chrétienne et la première église
ethnique et ex commune et en tant que
tel
et
par conséquent on évite soigneusement de
se rendre au sein de cette communauté
hérétiques et vous il ya un clivage dans
les premiers siècles de du pèlerinage on
visite cet endroit et on honore la
communauté judéo chrétienne qui se
trouve comme étant l'héritière de la
première communauté de jérusalem dans la
deuxième période on les rejette on
excommunie et on évite de les visiter
par conséquent ici il y a une tradition
qui remonte à cet endroit là et on est
sûr que là on est dans un tel endroit
précisément où avait lieu le
rassemblement de la première communauté
judéo chrétiens de jérusalem